all right lita pal drake what's up with
rory calhoun
we welcome back oh excuse me don't i
said i like your watch i like those big
numbers well that's a
listen there's a reason for that it's
it's called you can't see
so it's time yeah i see that well i
don't have any numbers because i can't
read the number i got dots
i see dots all the time you know who he
is
francis timothy mcgowan uh you left out
the michael
francis timothy michael mcgowan mccowan
mcconnell and that's why we call him
rory calhoun because he's got all those
other things
all those initials come out to rory
calvin welcome back to capital and to
nebraska
it's marvelous to see you mr calhoun
well thank you it's so nice of you to
say that
well listen have you been having to jet
back and forth
between la and dc in order to
shoot a lot of the scenes for capital no
i haven't uh
i think some of the group think about
roy caro
rory calhoun here 36 years old he just
aged terribly
up in washington right now but
i wasn't included in that and uh
i think the there's been a rumor that we
may all be going in september but no
one's confirmed that so
but i'm holding september open anyhow is
that for the big wedding
well the wedding's over the wedding has
yeah the wedding's taken place and tyler
married julie
and now everybody is really biting at
each other
and all the intrigue and the nastiness
and the goodness
what a cool name rory calhoun is there a
cooler name
it's all you know one big ball and
churning around in there like that
well how do you know how to spit
something out i was capital doing in the
ratings because it was the first um
soap opera of new soap opera to come
down the pike in about nine years so how
are you holding up now
well i can only go by the last rating
the last rating was we were in the first
10 of daytime shows
i don't know if that meant uh soaps or
all shows
but as you know in this business next
week it can change
you can be 12 or 15. and then lead to
[ __ ] them you didn't lead a [ __ ] rory
calhoun
you go back down to five you just
uh we haven't been on long enough it's
17 months to really get a flat
you know 11 on it where you know that
every week
you have x amount of viewers who are
going to
she's calling them out for having low
ratings because she is
the best slash worst interviewer that's
ever
[ __ ] lived uh view your show
and there's a lot of people who are into
other shows
and we come in the middle of a half hour
yeah
so uh we have to come in the middle of
an hour show and
it's kind of hard to get people away
from a show they like and they've been
watching for a number of years
to switch over and go to you but with
little luck
we might get some of them don't touch my
things what if she gets really nasty
don't touch my desk don't touch my desk
uh don't judge leaders desk thanks i
would think shooting in washington dc
would be fr
washington not with problems because
there are demonstrations you know
everybody is coming to washington to
demonstrate
yeah but this was in 1983 that's over
nobody's demonstrating in washington dc
anymore
all right that's a that's a [ __ ] time
that's a bygone era all right no one
does that anymore
it's 2021 demonstrating in washington dc
is over we've all learned our lesson
listen to this [ __ ] [ __ ] think she
is
one time or another and i understood
that you had just shot
uh a series of sequences around the
washington monument
it was already in the can and this was
at the time if you'll recall
not too long ago where they that that
man was going to
bomb had you know supposedly planted
yeah in the monument but the thing is if
they had blown up the monument
you know how do you people handle that
well me i don't know i i
just don't know uh
i how do you answer something like that
you know if i was the government i died
you answered something like that rory is
already getting
pissed at her the guy in the slammer for
a long time
as a citizen i'd be irate because it is
one of our monuments as an american
and uh that would upset me but what can
i
individually do about it go grab the guy
and shoot him i don't think i'd better
try that
how's carolyn jones doing i don't know
i haven't heard uh about care
of from carolyn or about her damn rory
calhoun he left home at 17 to escape
beatings from his stepfather and began
hot-wiring cars after robbing several
jewelry stores this is
robbing several jewelry stores in the
30s 40s
he stole cars and drove it across state
lines this made it a federal offense
and he was recaptured he was sentenced
to three years in prison
he served the census the united states
at the united states medical center for
federal prisoners
in springfield missouri he remained
there until he was paroled
shortly before his 21st birthday calhoun
worked at a number of odd jobs including
mechanic logger california redwoods hard
rock minor
and a cowboy in arizona look at him
that had [ __ ] this guy was was a
[ __ ]
criminal a jewel thief in two months
then i
i have their phone number and
i call there and the machine says
this is a machine but we will get back
to you and so far uh
nothing i like when machines announce
that they're machines
i don't want to be fooled like that
streamlabs [ __ ] so i don't really know
well i know that she is in a coma
and we just i heard that was a rumor
yeah well
it came out in print now whether that
makes it true or not we're not saying i
just heard
based what's someone talking about and
they said that uh
had been retracted or something there's
the little article
carolyn jones said to be in a coma and
also
she's suffering from cancer in los
angeles hospital
the the strange thing about this you
take a character who is now developed
you remember carolyn jones also from the
adams family yeah she paid
marticia yeah you take a character who
is develop
and developing and then how difficult is
it to replace that character you know to
still be the same person but put another
actor in there
oh it's awfully tough because because
someone
when you create a role oh no yeah
carolyn this this interviews in 1983
carolyn jones died in 1983.
uh 1930 to 1983 joseph diagnosed with
colon cancer in 1981 after experience
recurring stomach problems but continued
to work while her colleagues
uh the children because she was being
treated for alters after a period of an
apparent remission the cancer returned
in 82
in july 1983 she fell into a coma at her
home in west hollywood
where she died caroline was cremated on
august 4th in a memorial service held at
glassbend
willin mortuary in
california her ashes were
uh entered into her mother's crypt at
memorial park
she donated her marticia costume in a
wig to the academy of motion pictures of
arts and sciences
while a collection of family scripts
were donated to the bayley britain ucla
she was mortish adams
it's awfully tough for somebody to go in
there and try to recreate it because
they are used to seeing it a certain way
with certain kinds of looks and your
particular
personality uh good or bad evil or
or pleasant uh injected into it and
someone else would do it in another way
getting the same idea across but it's a
different person doing it
it's difficult yeah you acted with
marilyn monroe
yes could she really act
there it is the thing with leader pal
drake's interviews is
even you think okay this th this is
going to be if this is going to be fine
i mean you know she's being she's been
all right
and then and then
she asked something like this you acted
with marilyn monroe
could she really act what
the [ __ ]
is wrong with this woman
what is wrong
with this woman
with marilyn monroe yes could she really
act
i think marilyn monroe
was really a fine actress and i'll tell
you why
because she had a style that no one else
has ever had
before or since and
when you heard that breathless thing
people have tried to copy it
and i've seen them try to do it in film
not the same
she was my buddies are saying that she
uh clearly wants to [ __ ] rory calhoun i
think so
the body language is there
when you can't just look at marilyn
monroe as a sex symbol
although that's what she was want to
[ __ ] bet
known for you know she was that that gal
that everybody
uh wanted to keep on the side you know
but
i like rory and man i like rory calhoun
that gal that everybody wanted to keep
on the side [ __ ] yeah rory
hell yeah rory's the man oh [ __ ] fsf's
in the chat for rory calhoun
what a [ __ ] hero look at that face
look at that look at that smug look at
that smug smile
look at that smug smile he died in 1999.
that's so wait a second he died at age
76
this interview was done he was only
60 years old this is
this is him at 60. i had a terrible 60
buddy
it's not it's not the best looking 60
year old i've seen
this 60 year old
but she she was a craftsman
and knew what she was doing how
difficult is it to decide
when you're given the opportunity to do
movie roles how good it's going to be
like
that terrible thing you did motel hell
that came out about a year ago
it's called alcohol alcoholism rice here
you're right
you're right can you you can't go into
it knowing this is going to be awful
no i mean you you can just hope for the
best you you take it
you think he banged marilyn monroe i
think he banged marilyn monroe
he starts out to make a bad picture they
may have a low budget but they
they hope it will you know do something
no one starts out to make a bad picture
but unfortunately sometimes they turn
out that way
what a charming fellow i like rory
cowboy did quite well
at the box office oddly enough and and
it got nothing but raps
you know from from the reviewers and and
uh
they didn't like me in it they still
thought i ought to be on a horse instead
of playing
another character but and that's fine
and dandy you know everyone's entitled
to their opinion but it did quite well
at the box
well good i'm glad something good came
out yeah you know you have wonderful
eyebrows
you have wonderful eyebrows well they
don't come she she wants him
she wants him you could tell you could
tell she wants him
look at how dark they are your hair is
great but your eyebrows look
like there's a lot of gray in those eyes
look at
look at that look at oh
oh oh we're seeing a little crush here
oh boy oh
boy
nailed it just she [ __ ] nailed it
look at that
look at that
he had sex with her he had to you think
he [ __ ] her
very charismatic no you're right he
probably got a lot of [ __ ]
fairly dark yeah listen i loved you
all don't stop now that's why i need you
[ __ ] what a charming man
what a charming man he knows what he's
doing
don't stop now huh good for him
hold on you're alone
well we can rock
oh did you catch that did you catch it
oh my god did you catch that
you're alone we could work on some oh
boy oh boy
don't stop now that's why i need you
that i'm old and alone
oh old you're alone well we can
walk up something we can work
something out
we can work something
out we can
work something
out
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
wait we're on the air rory calhoun what
a pleasure what a pleasure may capital
be very successful
we look for you every day here on 10 11
strong at 1 30
capital love it roy gallahold thank you
thank you please stay with
wow i will i would love to interview her
i gotta get in contact with her i'm
going to get her on the show
i want to interview leader pal drake i
want to see i'm going to ask her all the
famous people that she [ __ ]